good afternoon everyone it's a pleasure
to welcome you all to the center for art
science and technology symposium being
material we're delighted you're here on
this rainy day my name is Philip Currie
I have a responsibility for the arts as
associate provost here at MIT in a
moment I'm going to say a few words
about cast and about the symposium at
least briefly but the first thing I wish
to do is introduce MIT s Provost Marty
Schmidt I want to say a few words about
Marty before he comes up here he is
going to introduce this symposium for us
on behalf of MIT in 2014
Martin Schmidt was appointed Provost of
MIT that may be the most difficult and
taxing job at the Institute except
perhaps for the position he held before
becoming Provost that was associate
provost for all of MIT space and
facilities including its renovation and
renewal budgets Marty was a master at
negotiating some of the most thorny
issues and resolving I cannot tell you
how many space wars you can imagine at a
place like MIT which is so laboratory
driven it's a really hard job and he was
so good at it that the then Provost
asked him to also take on responsibility
for all of MIT s industrial interactions
including our technology licensing
office and our corporate relations
office he did both these jobs so well
for six years that same Provost I
mentioned became president and not
surprisingly Marty in time became his
Provost our Provost he is mi t--'s chief
academic officer he's in charge of the
entire academic budget of this institute
at MIT he is the go-to person and he's a
delight
work with I can say that I've had a lot
of experience with Provost's in my own
career and I'm hardly alone in that
assessment he earned his PhD in 1988
here at the Institute he joined the
faculty right then and he's been here
ever since in the department of
electrical engineering and computer
science from 99 1999 to 2006 he served
as the director of the Microsystems
technology lab laboratories MTL MTL is
an inter department laboratory one of mi
t--'s larger labs and in fact it
provides shared research infrastructure
for all of the campuses activities in
micro and nanotechnology and it supports
the research environment staff students
500 in total that's non-trivial his
teaching and research is in the areas of
micro and nano fabrication he is the
author of more than 200 journals and a
peer-reviewed conference proceedings he
has received many research and teaching
awards too many to mention here he's the
inventor of more than 30 issued US
patents and he's active in the
consulting industry for the
commercialization of technology his
research group has transferred a number
of new technologies to industry and he's
co-founded or has been the co-inventor
of the core technology for six startup
companies most important for this
occasion
Marty Schmidt cares a lot about the
Center for art science and technology
and for the Arts
broadly speaking at MIT and for that I
and my colleagues are deeply grateful
Marty Schmidt I'll stand by
[Applause]
Wow Philip thank you I wish I had
recorded that I could be my daily
affirmation well welcome everybody it's
a pleasure to be here if I'm sure for
many of you this is a return visit to
MIT or maybe MIT is your home for those
of you where this is your first time
here the only thing I'll tell you is
that the weather's never like this it's
more likely to snow in April in Boston
but on behalf of MIT in the Center for
art science and technology I'm pleased
to welcome you all this afternoon
cast brings together artists scientists
engineers and humanists through
residency's interdisciplinary courses
ongoing projects in symposia I'm going
to read from my notes so I don't forget
anything so I apologize if this is a
little stilted we're gratified to see
individuals from such a broad range of
disciplines and backgrounds gathered
here today to participate in being
material which will explore the powerful
new possibilities for design and
fabrication created by programmable
responsive and self-organizing materials
which are driving much of recent
research in biology engineering media
and robotics labs at MIT and beyond this
materials revolution as some have called
it offers a perfect occasion to examine
some of the unexpected intersections of
the digital material worlds and revisit
questions raised in Nicholas Negroponte
a path breaking 1995 book being digital
and I'm looking forward to hearing
Nicholas's of marks shortly I'd like to
congratulate the organizers of this
event for assembling such an impressive
group of contributors and tackling such
an ambitious range of topics actually
from programming languages and machine
vision to clothing design and
environmental politics for attempting
the seemingly impossible task of
discussing all these things at once the
programmable wearable audible livable
and invisible
we thank the session organizers and I'll
list them in the order in which you'll
see the sessions Skylar Tibbits who's an
assistant professor and founder of the
self-assembly
in the Department of Architecture Lila
Kinney the executive director of arts
initiatives and MIT cast Evans a porn
keen and Sahin distinguished professor
chair music and theatre arts and faculty
director of MIT cast Rebecca you chill
is also here postdoctoral fellow and
lecturer in the Department of
Architecture and finally Stefan Helmick
Stefan is a professor of anthropology
and program had in anthropology in
addition while he's not with us right
now but he will be with us this evening
I want to thank the honorary chair of
today's event Ron Kurtz
Ron is an alumni who has supported this
symposium that brings together two of
his passions arts and material science
when Ron came to MIT in 1950s to study
course 3 which was his department was a
department of metallurgy where heavy
industry was the focus at labs with big
machinery forges and welding operations
were the norm a profound shift in the
field towards engineering science
eventually led to the transformation of
the department into material science and
engineering
Ron's keen interest in ongoing changes
in the field led him to support the
design studio taught by Skylar Tibbits
and related active material summit
organized with cast in 9 2015 while a
student at MIT
Ron developed a lifelong interest in
photography which he collects he's given
many works from his collections to the
Institute and endowed a gallery
dedicated to the photography dedicated
to photography at the MIT Museum long as
Ron is a long-standing member of the
Council for the Arts at MIT which was
founded in 1972 by then President Jerome
Wiesner as an international volunteer
group of alumni and Friends of the Arts
the council's mission is to act as a
catalyst for the development of a
broadly based highly participatory
program in the arts firmly founded on
teaching practice and research at the
institute ron has made a commitment to
ensuring that students are highly
attuned to the relationship among the
arts science and engineering and were
grateful for his continued support of
cast
I certainly hope that if you have an
opportunity to see Ron tonight you can
thank him for all his contributions and
for his help with this symposium so in
closing let me just thank you once again
for coming and welcome you to MIT I
anticipate that this day and a half of
intellectual exchange will produce new
questions to ask new research problems
to solve a new creative approaches to
try thank you very much thank you very
much Marty it's great you're here so
cast was created in 2012 with the
endorsement of Rafael rife who was then
Provost and is now president of MIT and
it also came through a generous grant
from the Andrew W mellon Foundation a
grant that has been renewed since once
so we're optimistic there's a future for
this Center I'd like to recognize and
thank my cofounders of this Center
deborah fitzgerald and adele santos they
were deans at the time of the creation
of the center and stayed with it until
they stepped down
Deborah Dean of the School of Humanities
Arts and Social Sciences and Adele Dean
of the School of Architecture and
planning and their successors
Melissa nobles Dean of shafts humanities
Arts and Social Sciences and Hashem
Sarkis whom I see over there Dean of
Architecture and planning they have kept
the ship steady for us grateful to them
we all are since its inception cast has
awarded close to a million dollars in
support for academic courses artists
residences workshops lecture
demonstrations seminars films and
concerts 108 projects to date at the
intersections of art science and
technology the faculty director Marty
mentioned Evans the pouran Kenan Sahin
distinguished professor music and Lila
Kinney executive director of arts
initiatives work with a selection
committee to identify and curate these
projects and we're grateful for this
committee's collective vision
it's a terrific committee now symposia
like being mature
are an important part of the center's
mandate to bring together artists
engineers scientists humanists to
address vital topics of shared concern
and to disseminate emerging research and
creative projects to the wider public
being material will showcase recent
developments in material systems and
design placing this work in dialogue
with kindred and contrasting philosophy
art practice and critique the panel's
this afternoon will aspire explore two
new and unexpected and they'll aspire to
two new and unexpected meetings of the
digital and material worlds in assessing
these developments it's no surprise that
the co-chairs of the symposium looked to
MIT history and especially to Nicholas
Negroponte ease pressing at nineteen
ninety-five book being digital as a
touchstone we're really honored really
honored that Nicholas has agreed to make
opening remarks Nicholas Negroponte he
hardly needs an introduction to this
audience but let me highlight just a few
features of his boundary crossing work
and his vision as a public intellectual
trained as an architect at MIT
Nicholas joined the faculty in 1966 he
became interested early on in
computer-aided design and he created the
architecture machine group in 1967 a
hybrid research lab design studio and
think-tank which was the prototype for
the MIT Media Lab which he founded with
jerome Wiesner our thirteenth president
in 1985 as early as 1980 Nicholas
announced that computing is not about
computers anymore it's about living he
was one of the first people to
understand that media consumption social
relations and financial transactions
would move to digital platforms from
atoms to bits as he memorably put it
Nicholas has taken special pleasure over
the years and being told that an idea or
a prediction of his was dead wrong and
living to see it come to pass five or
ten years later the negroponte a switch
as it was nicknamed foresaw that things
that were wired like telephones would
become wireless and things that were
wireless like TVs would become wired
touchscreen interfaces GPS Google street
views electronic books and newspapers
wearable computing and sensory tracking
all were explored in early research
projects in the architecture machine
group that became the Media Lab now
after 15 years of leading the Media Lab
as its founding director Nicholas
stepped down and is now chairman
emeritus I think it is fair to say that
there is no better known MIT division or
organization anywhere on this planet
than the MIT Media Lab Nicholas is
ingenious leadership has had a lot to do
with this fact in 2005 his sights turned
elsewhere and he began working on One
Laptop Per child a billion dollar
nonprofit enterprise dedicated to
developing an inexpensive power
efficient network enabled computer for
children around the world especially in
under-served
locations inspired by Seymour Papert
professor at the time here
his constructionist pedagogy I remember
Nicholas giving me one of these
prototypes with an Arabic keyboard to
experiment with and it was just really
interesting to look and work with the
scope and ambition of the project has
inspired country countries social
enterprises and low-cost low-tech
approaches the technological innovations
for large populations who live on the
other side of the digital divide and
Nicholas has been a founder catalyst and
angel investor in more than 40
enterprises including well-known
entities in our contemporary cultural
landscape such as Wired magazine Tech
Talks and I got to name a few I've known
Nicholas for three decades he's a
colleague and a friend and I think our
most recent collaboration was in helping
to recruit the current director of the
Media Lab whom by my lights and I think
by Nicholas's and by our Provost is just
doing a splendid job in leading somewhat
in Nicholas's image that lab today he's
here to speak on the topic of bin
digital please join me
while committing Nicholas Negroponte
[Applause]